welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host definition aka the guy
who's
over the moon that i no longer have to
stare at henry cavill's upper lip
and what an amazing day it is for dc
fans
zack snyder hosted a man of steel watch
along party on his vero today
and at the end of it it was announced
that his long-awaited snyder cut would
be making its way to hbo max in 2021
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down everything you need to
know about the announcement
and just what an incredible day it is
unless of course you're just whedon
anyway before we get into that make sure
you hit the subscribe button and please
drop a thumbs up
as we're going to be doing a big snyder
cup video tomorrow
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our breakdown of
the snyder cut news
okay so if you've been following the
channel for the last two years
you'll know that we've been reporting on
this snyder cut for what seems like a
lifetime
it initially seemed like it would never
see the light of day and though it
trended often on twitter
we didn't really get an official
announcement on the project until today
it was rumored that zach needed an extra
20 million dollars to finish special
effects
and to add some additional scenes but it
seemed unlikely that he would ever get
the funding due to warner brothers
losing out
60 million on the theatrical cut of the
movie still
hope lingered on and we kept expecting
to get good news of it one day
even in the wake of reports slamming the
project and saying the fandom was toxic
well it looks like the wait was worth it
and we now know that warner brothers met
with zach on february 6th where he
screened the movie
and they then agreed to put it into
production now obviously the pandemic
has caused a hold up on everything
but still the film will be seeing a
release in 2021.
today after the live stream which did
feature henry cavill with a mustache
which
give me ptsd snyder released the
following statement
i want to thank hbo max and warner
brothers for this brave gesture of
supporting artists
and allowing their true visions to be
realized also a special thank you to all
those involved in the snyder cup
movement for making this a reality
so really great words from zach and i'm
so glad that his vision's finally
getting brought to the screen
now how this format will take release we
don't know yet
but it is rumor that the project will be
four hours long
it was initially thought to be three and
a half however rumors today
have re-emerged that it will indeed be
four hours this does open up the
possibility of a mini series
but we'll have to see as time goes on
the hollywood reporter did just announce
that it may be split into six episodes
but they don't know as the team are
currently in the midst of reassembling
as much post-production material as
possible
they're also pulling together han zimmer
and junky xl to rescore the movie
the cast will record additional dialogue
and the visual effects will be finished
it was further stated by snyder to the
hollywood reporter it will be an
entirely new thing
and especially talking to those who
haven't seen the release movie
a new experience apart from that movie
you probably saw one-fourth of what i
did
i always thought it was a thing that in
20 years maybe somebody would do a
documentary and i could lend them the
footage
little snippets of a cut no one has ever
seen with a new platform and streaming
services
you can have something like this you
can't release something like this
theoretically
but you could with a streaming service
it's an opportunity that wasn't there
two years ago to be honest
now it definitely is an amazing
opportunity for fans
and it feels like a massive development
but it does still hold a few
questions for example the release will
be in hbo max exclusive
which is only available in the us so we
don't know if it will be released in
other countries on other formats but
definitely watch this space now
personally i'm just really happy and as
i'm sure you can guess
excited it's been something i've covered
for a while now
but i didn't actually believe that we
would ever get to see it
i loved man of steel batman v superman
and i felt like we as fans were robbed
of the complete trilogy and i wanted to
see it so badly
i thought warner brothers were too
stubborn to ever release it and it would
just be something that lived on in fans
imaginations
however hearing this news today has
really cheered me up especially
because i won't have to look at that
stupid mustache again
it will be interesting to see what
happens with the dc eu now
especially robert pattinson's batman as
if the movie is successful
it could lead to there being two
directions that the franchise could go
off into
watch this space but yeah fun times also
shout out to the fans who follow the
channel everyone who's commenting on a
video
and has helped me talk about something
that i love of course
as well huge congratulations to zack
snyder this guy
tragically lost his daughter had his
film taken away from him
and all his hard work kind of brushed to
the side then the pandemic showed up
but that can't stop the film being
released now and i'm just so happy for
the guy
so thank you zach thank you everyone i
love you
watching this video you're kind of like
my best mate you
you listening to this and i'll sp i'll
speak to you soon tomorrow probably
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the news and how hyped you
are for the project
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please drop a
thumbs up
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of the news that ruby rose has
stepped
away from the batwoman before season two
i'll leave that linked at the end and if
you want to support the channel from as
little as 99 cents a month then please
click the join button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early
if you want to come chats after the show
either follow us at heavyspoilers or
click the discord link in the
description below
every month we give away free movies to
people are subscribed to the channel
and this month you can win the marvel
phase 3 part 2 box set and all you have
to do is comment on a video and make
sure you sub with notifications on
the more videos you comment on the more
you have a chance of winning so make
sure you get involved
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 15th of june and the set
will be shipped out from then to ever
gets the prize
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes
so if that's the kind of thing you like
hit subscribe thank you for taking the
time to watch this
i've been definition you've been the
best and i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you